hello excuse me I I don't suppose you
gentlemen have an extra one of those for
a thirsty lady do you are you the
Thirsty lady yes I am they've definitely
got another one for you oh oh nice I'm
Donna I'm Joe my friend Roy hello my
grandson Peter Peter nice to meet you
hello Donna
uh Roy why don't you uh give down to
your seat
I like this seat why don't you get the
[__] over here so I can talk to you all
right
thank you
there you go Donna
thank you I kind of wanted this to be a
you know special night for me and Pops
because you know he's not feeling so
well he's you're a prostitute what do
you know that she is a hooker no offense
darling you're beautiful no offense take
him that's not nice I mean that's a very
mean thing to say is this you a big
takeaway from our conversation I don't
know what to do you take me to lunch and
tell me you're dying I I scrambled I
thought maybe your last wish was some
[__]
oh excuse me I'll let you boys hash this
out be back in a minute um what the what
the [__] is a wheel Roy you believe this
my grandson thinks I need a hooker to
get laid I don't know I said in your
grandpa was the Wilt Chamberlain of
Staten Island first of all if I tattooed
every girl that I ever banged on my body
I'd be [__] Memento over here who's
momentum what did you think was gonna
happen
what if I fell in love with him yep he
you're playing with fire
well we're here we might as well have
some fun I'd like to make a toast to the
most handsome gentleman in this joint
where are they
[Music]
gonna be a clown a real clown Hong Kong
yeah hey man can I get a picture with
you hey bartender give me a root beer
float over here
personal joke glad you guys are having
fun because it did cost five grand for
the Sinatra Suite so five thousand
dollars for a sweet yeah for a hawker
Sinatra better be in there
[Applause]
are you kidding me gummy bears in a
crystal dish this is so Swanky and you
got strawberries and champagne Petey
watch too many movies is this [__]
classy huh where'd you get that I feel
like Daddy Warbucks well I was an orphan
all right
[Music]
oh
look at that
[Music]
this is fun I'm really glad that we did
this you put a smile on my face tonight
I'm always happy we had a great time
speaking of Roy where where is he
where's Donna
they're in the bedroom holy [__] isn't
that like having sex no they're watching
the [__] Giants you Meathead come on
what do you think
not to bring the mood down or anything
but you know it just gets me to thinking
I don't know what I'm gonna do when when
you're gone I'm gonna have nobody can
start with that mushy [__] again no it's
just you know I I don't know what I'm
gonna do without you you know Peter who
gives a [__] about tomorrow it's gonna
come no matter who's here and who's not
here so don't worry about it
at least your plan worked for somebody
let's get the [__] yeah let's go
yeah I just might put a trigger like a
sharp shooter in his prime is a new 20
but I'm young forever one day they won't
be able to name one who's better
my favorite records cko like mkto's
classic all around the world